Wesley a Titanic struggle between two
incredible players what did you feel
made that separation in this matchup
uh well
you know it kind of
kind of need some help you know help
from your opponent like I've gone either
way
and uh try to get some good time
management and kind of help a little bit
that I got some practice in Berlin
playing speed shift but uh yeah really
the first game went quite smoothly to to
be fair I you mean the first game of the
playoffs yeah because you guys also play
the classical match you had some chances
it felt like you got that extra Pawn did
you feel like you were getting in the
classical any traction in that game
probably nothing really like I was very
surprised when he played HX
I thought Queen takes C5 was pretty
what's the main line and it's pretty
easily holding 40. yeah Queen takes
Bishop F6 do you have six King E2 uh B
takes yeah you don't want to get him
Checkmate yes
and now I mean I analyze this with black
like if Rook C1 probably just Knight
before check yeah
94 check or the computer doesn't like or
maybe okay B8 first
and then Knight D4 I think Rook to B3
Knight to D4 yes perhaps Knight to D4 no
this is what you analyze yeah
but this is the draw yes I was very
surprised why he started thinking a long
time and he played H6 and then I thought
I had some chances of probably nothing
really big I was happy except Knight C6
if he played Knight A6 I have C6
I thought Knight a66 but yeah computer
doesn't give much but I thought white
has a very big Advantage here yeah
before it's coming but yeah computer
gets all zeros G3 yeah like here I
thought I have chances but I couldn't
really find anything so I was kind of
confused during the game whether it's
all part of his preparation or I'm
mixing up something he was indeed taking
a long time uh to get this position but
after that he did precisely calculate
everything to make a draw yeah
that first game of the playoffs yeah it
felt like he makes smoothly slowly well
you're gaining a nice Advantage out of
the opening if I like yeah for sure I
mean except D6 I thought D5 equals right
away yes yeah but then he spent a lot of
time and then on move nine
but yeah I thought okay be it was a
mistake and here I had I was very happy
because I had a big Advantage I thought
but I you know yeah it wasn't pleasant
defending for black I think he almost
equalized at some point
like the bishop is just
very just Bishop on basis was he coming
with the Knight on B8 like what was his
plan with his uh Knight to C6 A5 A5
after Queen to A2 or yeah Queen A2 A5
p59
Knight d8 yeah doesn't matter yeah 97
Knight C5 yeah I thought I had a pretty
big Advantage but so I was trying to
push it but then I couldn't really find
anything concrete but I I mean he
probably almost equalized at some point
this was the big moment when he had this
opportunity to play
C4 D4 yeah V4 I think I play C4 D4 yes
yeah and then he gained some space yes
but still there's some pressure left uh
for a Blitz game for a Blitz game yeah
for sure but yeah I was trying to put
pressure but then I realized it's just
all about that time
and uh yeah he didn't really have a
clear way to equalize maybe oh here
maybe instead of uh at what point
instead of Rook D1 on move 40
I guess Queen D1 also loses him because
I darkest night yeah 21 take take okay
okay two Rook to A8 and the Knight gets
trapped yeah I mean the difference in a
position of knights is huge that is
beautiful yes so I was very pleased when
I won this game yes and then but then
the second game I came up with the same
idea to what he did in the classical
yeah it was very I was very surprised
because I thought white had absolutely
nothing if I go for Mainland with B5 but
I decided not to check if
analysis and then after E4 couldn't
really remember I guess I played okay so
yeah but I was very happy on move um I
thought Bishop F4 was slightly a mistake
I was very happy when I took the bishop
on C2 I thought I was even a little
better yeah and better and you were
indeed yeah and then I messed up real
quick like I relaxed too early yeah
midnight before
prevents all the trades Knight A4 was a
good move yeah now I couldn't trade
pieces I guess I'm still better but
I couldn't still not an easy position
especially with a low time control yeah
and then you found Knight F5 and now
what are you at all worried at this
point or did you feel like you're very
very close to I'm happy to get the
quality
I'm happy to get the opposite colored
Bishops that means it's very good
throwing chances no matter what happens
but of course I knew that I need to be
very precise
uh but then I kind of messed up my F6
probably a mistake
because of this bishop to B6 perhaps F5
instead of yeah F5 I just forgot about
this bishop B6 business yeah yeah F5 and
then Bishop B5 should be and
yeah quite an easy draw and then I have
to say Oh I thought on move 38 38 oh 13
there I thought yeah he should take on
F6 it's the icon X F6 first and now
Bishop to C3 yeah so not allow you to
close the position up with F5 no sorry
F6 was a big mistake yeah yeah yeah this
does indeed yeah probably Fabiano will
convert this position serious chances
yeah yeah yeah actually it's uh yeah
it's it also I had very little time so
he probably would convert but still
after F5 you you had to defend
accurately for 70 plus moves you did so
yeah you continue into the Champions
bracket tomorrow you will be facing
uh the rating favorite going into this
event Hikaru Nakamura how do you feel
about that particular matchup you know
him so well I mean he's the only one
who's won any classical games right yeah
oh yeah he's the only one one in
classical games I mean he's in very good
form I thought since it streams non-stop
that these chess would be affected but
he comes to this event very very well
prepared and he's playing really really
well yeah so it's gonna be
interesting yeah I thought that
with this full-time job
as a student at the same at a classical
chess would be affected but no he's
playing like Magnus cars on this
tournament
he is indeed but uh yeah
it's showing as well I don't shy away
from that guys any questions yeah good
question for you Wesley uh at the time
that you did say to the Arbiter Chris
bird uh I'm gonna claim a draw on the 50
move rule in your mind how many moves
did you played
oh I was pretty sure that you were
comfortably above 50. but how many did
you think you might have was only like
56 I in the end yeah I thought for sure
that we'd reach 50 moves at that point
without any pawn moves just so I mean I
mean I look at the TV screen and I
realized that we played like almost 130
movies
but you were you were getting close to
the 75 move where the Arbiter was going
to step in oh yeah not that close but I
claimed because I was wondering if I
could take the pawn on E5 if you wanted
to stop yourself from losing the 50 move
rule chance I didn't want them but it
was also quite risky because if
if you're wrong then you you get uh then
your opponent gets a minute right or
something yeah too but so yeah big deal
yeah it's very risky you think it's
risky to give your opponent two minutes
so what what is he gonna do
you got two minutes
yeah in that position but when my king
was uh on was cut off on the G file I
was slightly worried that he could
attack The Rook for my Bishop at some
point like Rook takes B3 and A4 a59 I
had to be very careful that this is a
draw but um
yeah if if they're good to say like uh
of course I could just take the pawn E5
but then we keep playing right and uh
I was just pretty confident that it's
gonna be 50 moves but but it's hard to
say in a Blitz game because
you can get penalized for for the wrong
claim so um I think I've done it before
Wesley uh very well done good luck to
tomorrow in your match with Hikaru thank
you so much guys absolutely